yeah i think we met at the playboy
mansion i want to say yeah what year
which i mean that would have been
surprised me
i think early like maybe like 2002 or
something oh wow how many times have you
been to the playboy mansion
and i got kicked out
i forgot i forget why i was kicked out
probably running around naked jumping in
the grotto i think it was more of a
cocaine thing oh really yeah i think i
was like
i think i was doing cocaine like really
blatantly out in the open right
and they're like there's bathrooms for
that
yeah there's cocaine room for that yeah
yeah um yeah you know actually was not a
fan of hard drugs right he was pretty
anti hard drugs from what i remember
yeah you never saw him touch anything
really but for sure you know he was
definitely he was a fan of the quaaludes
i think that was kind of well known you
know you hear lots of stories that he
had his special doctor that took care of
special needs
you know how do you get invited to the
playboy mansion is it like a letter or a
phone call yeah steve how'd you get
invited i can't remember
i just showed up yeah
i think i actually do remember
and that it was
uh it came through like the jackass
channels okay there was like the jackass
guys
somebody probably around the time one of
the movies came out and they got you up
there is like hey he's got a new movie
out let's get him up here it'll be wacky
and zany watch him create all kinds of
problems and they're like oh yeah
that'll be fun oh wait his problem is
actually doing cocaine on the front lawn
no we can't have that yeah
we didn't realize he was coming in
character how many times how many times
have you been there uh
3 000.
like i was there every weekend oh really
wow that's happening at how starting at
how young and what's word these are like
post dated because there's no more
playboy mansion yeah what is it what is
the place it's not just a mansion a
museum without the playboy
without that well it's not even that it
should have been that if they were smart
that's what they would have done they
would have preserved it but instead some
dude took it over bought it and like
literally like changed it all like how
do you go and deface a historical
monument like why why i seem to recall
this story
i remember the story was
that half sold it
while he was still alive yes but the
deal was that the guy had to keep it the
way it was until half died not only that
but have had the right to live in it
right until he died so what that did was
force the people who would basically
taken over the company and taken over
all of his stuff to try and like make
him as uncomfortable and miserable as
possible while he was still there so
they were doing stuff like telling him
like you can no longer have you know
your guests over in the parking you can
never no longer have the parking guys do
your parking for you you can no longer
have your poker nights or your movie
nights or whatever these guests aren't
allowed anymore you know whatever they
would just like take away all of his
freedoms to the point where he felt so
like isolated and miserable that he
didn't even want to live and i think
that's kind of sadly that's that's kind
of how it went down and wow damn yeah
and he sold it because like financially
he just couldn't personally keep it up
yeah so basically what happened was you
know and i don't want to go too deep but
there was a uh let's say a buyout
uh with a certain company because he was
in a lot of trouble say around 2007 2008
right around the time right after we
shot up there actually we did the two
cory's shoot up there my ex-wife see
where we shot in the uh
right right not where we where we shot
up there no yeah yeah
we weren't shooting up there but we were
shooting up there
uh yeah no so we so we were shooting for
the two coreys and and uh and have
asked my ex-wife susie to be in the
magazine on the show and that was part
of it and i got to actually direct huff
which was really cool
because you know
all the other show runners were like
scared to touch it like uh we don't want
to talk to the guy what are we gonna say
i'm like don't worry i got this you know
what i mean so i was like okay here's
what we need you to do
and he was great he was very helpful
very cool very cooperative
um and yeah he asked in a very kind of
amazing way like it's so cool to have
that footage of i mean i'm not her so i
wasn't really asked to be in it but
to be her
you know he like sits her down at the
dinner table which we've sat at with him
a thousand times you know it's like
where he would like have the dinner in
between the movie i don't do you ever go
for a movie night on a sunday oh yeah
cause that's kind of like that's more
like the casual chill like only really
close
right right right but you would have
been you know if you didn't screw up and
duplicate
anyway um so so that's kind of how it
happened for me i mean i went up to one
of the big parties you know and then
like five years later i was invited back
for a movie night and then like once i
went to a few of the movie nights
eventually i was invited to come sunday
during the afternoon by ron smith
and when i went in the afternoon a
couple times hef liked me you know he
saw me around and he was like hey you
know what
you're a cool guy i was like thanks he's
like if you want to come on fridays or
saturdays anytime you're welcome anytime
on the weekends you're welcome so my
name was added to the permanent list so
basically i didn't have to get clearance
i could bring whatever girls i want
unless it was a big party where you
still had to get you know
whatever authorized for your guests but
um but yeah i was like on the permanent
list so any friday saturday sunday if i
wanted to come up if i wanted to bring
three girls four girls it didn't matter
i would just show up and roll up to the
gate and they would let me in
so and you said that you were married at
that time i was married at that time yes
so was it your inclination to be married
and bring three or four girls no no no
this was not then oh gotcha right i'm
saying that's where my status was and
then once i got divorced then yes i was
up there quite frequently with a lot of
guests three or four girls man that's
pretty fun for somebody that's never
been
for somebody's never been like what's a
party at the playboy mansion here was my
whole theory my own theory was i didn't
want to
bring i i didn't a lot of people say we
don't want to bring sam to the beach
right right i didn't want to take sand
from the beach
you know what i mean like because i knew
that if i was then i wouldn't be invited
back very often you know i liked my
status and i knew that my status was
there because half saw that i respected
the boundary you know i mean it's all
about respecting the boundary he's the
host these are his girlfriends stay away
from his girls you know very simple i
enjoyed going up seeing my friends i had
like a second family up there so i
enjoyed seeing all of you know the
people that you see every week it was
like a weekly group and everybody got
together we watched movies we had fun we
had laughs stay away from his girls so
were you like i bring my own girls
super careful to bring like the hottest
chicks of course yeah but i mean that's
i don't date anything other than that
anyway right you know
seriously like i'm just i have very very
very high standards like always have and
like detrimentally so because those are
the girls that screw with your head the
most of course you know the harder they
are the more they're going to screw with
you right but whatever i was willing to
take that you know i love that
the risk you were willing to take i love
that big one for the team i love that
and i love even more your candor about
that yeah just to say hey man like hot
chicks right i mean that was my deal i
just you know when i was a single guy
i'm like
first and it's not because i like i love
everybody i love i love people i love
humans i love my fans whether they're
big fat skinny small tiny
rounds then it doesn't matter you know i
love them equally and i find beauty in
everybody
unless they're just a total dick bag and
then if they have them there's no beauty
there but you know his slumbuster is
like a prague model you know
but you know for me it's like it's like
if i'm gonna have to be with that person
and wake up every day to them and be
excited about it then you know it's
gotta be really really good because
otherwise there's gonna be three or four
more running around the corner they're
gonna be like cory come here this way
cool it's interesting man yeah and being
famous then in like the 80s and 90s is a
totally different world even you're like
oh no not then i'm talking now oh yeah
oh here we go i'm talking like in the
last 10 years nice
because no in the 80s and 90s i was shy
and awkward
didn't really date now you've hit your
stride well in between
okay let's let's back it up so between
my first marriage and my second marriage
i had a lot of growth between my second
and my third marriage i had a lot of
growth and by growth i mean boners
[Laughter]
yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's selling out
everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]